once you know you're gonna do a part is
your preparation and process the same is
there the same thing you go through in
getting ready to play the part or is it
different for everyone and will you tell
us parts of what it is I think I'm
always so tentative to ask an actor how
they do what they do but the thing is
it's also a mystery to me
so I can't really explain it and I used
to kind of Drive myself nuts trying to
be a little I'd see people making know
something I'm not doing enough you know
but really all that happens is I can't
stop thinking about it and then I
internalize a lot and then it needs to
come busting out and hopefully it
happens the moment do you work with the
script a lot or do you sort of yeah I
work with the script and I you know
there's some scenes that I don't like to
think about because sometimes they're
just too much and they just need to
erupt in a moment so I guess in that way
it varies and and almost in a way the
character demands it it's not about me
and what I need it's like what what this
what this person needs to become real is
always going to be different cuz we're
all so different that's interesting have
you had any ever had any characters that
were really hard to find your way into
they were a challenge that way more
challenging than others no because I I
don't think I take them on if I don't
feel like I don't have to know exactly
how I'm gonna do it but I know I can
yeah so here's the thing from my
perspective when you show up to work
your character is so thoroughly lived in
you have you have been this person it
feels like you've been this person
forever and that's not and and that's
not not every actor can do that is that
something you're conscious of do you
start I mean is it is it do you build
your day around it
it's remarkable so I'm curious what
aspect of it you're conscious of I don't
think it's that conscious really I don't
um I know why I've been hired the script
is there I will have lived for it for
you
certain amount of time I have to know
what a waste everyone's time you know
when I'm very aware of people having
lives and I know that there's a focus
and we're all there to tell this story
but I so it's very rare that I'll come
to a scene and feel like I need to
rehearse and rehearse and rehearse so I
pretty much do turn up ready to and
sometimes I kind of get to know a crew
and I'm like they're not gonna get a
ride on the first three tapes
I'm just give it all in till I'm gonna
hold back for three takes until I see
their [ __ ] together because they can't
use it if it's out of [ __ ] focus good
I like that